[Musik]
frohe Weihnachten mein Schatz auf unser
erstes Weihnachtsfest im schönen Bayern
oder wie man hier sagt Prost
ja das Bayern irgendwie ist jetzt hier
Jans anders als in Kölle aber feiner sie
gekocht Brust mein Schatz
[Musik]
der Mensch Josef was verschlägt dich
denn hierher du alte Hütte wie ist das
nur immer wieder schaffst das du alles
aber auch absolut alles falsch machst
wer ist das ja das ist ja Josef der
hilft mir in Bayern mit der Integration
Köln
darf ich dir ein Glas Champagner
anbieten ich weiß schon wir haben
natürlich auch Bier aber kein Kölsch das
habe ich schon gelernt von dir ne wir
haben Weizenbier wir haben starkes Bier
und wir haben mein Bock er lernt es
nicht er lernt ist einfach nicht an
Weihnachten gibt's in Bayern ein
Glühwein Glühwein ach das wusste ich
nicht ach ja da kann ich schon gehört da
gibt es ganz tolle Rezepte mit Bio
Rotwein Bio orange und der ganze
seltenen Zeile und sind genau ganz
fertig
[Applaus]
und bitte schön
oh jetzt hat's Euch verbringen Geld kann
man sehr gut abkühlen mit Schnaps
und ja prima jetzt
zum Essen halt ich habe einen leckeren
kokowa zubereitet ich liebe kokowei
fressen
an Kartoffelsalat und sonst nichts
aber das soll doch festlich werden ja
genau und darum gibt es noch mal einen
schönen Schnaps
so Würstel haben wir Kartoffelsalat
zu einem perfekten Heiligabend fällt
jetzt eigentlich bloß noch saftiger
Streit
aber wir streiten nicht aus hier Streits
nicht überhaupt nicht ja das kriegen wir
schon pass auf er zog du einfach einmal
was dir bei ihrer total auf den Sack
geht
bei meiner Wiebke nichts sie ist perfekt
wo ist mein Kübelchen
total zum kotzen findest ich
nicht da gibt es nichts Josef wir wir
lieben uns außer dass
ich habe keine eigene Meinung das ist
doch nicht Wahr oder Josef doch und dass
du dich nicht durchsetzen kannst und
immer alle das machst was die anderen
dir sagen ja also das liegt vielleicht
auch daran weil alles nur immer nach
deinem Willen gehen muss und du mich nur
rumkommandierst was ich komme an dir
dich rum du bist wie deine Mutter Gott
sei Dank sind wir hier in Bayern da
findet ihr auch der blöde Schachteln
lass meine aus dem Spiel und stell dir
vor ich hätte den letzten Satz ein
bisschen leiser gesagt dorelender
Wasser
und nicht vergessen immer schön fleißig
Schnaps nach schützen so und jetzt und
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
Heiligen Abend du bist eine Null ein
Weichei du kannst nichts du bist nichts
und du wirst auch nicht und du bist ein
Drache
[Musik]
Weihnachten in Bayern da gibt es auf der
ganzen weitenige Chinas und die zweite
drin die Gabi
[Musik]